hello and welcome to part three of
Detroit's you become human that's the
name of the game welcome back that looks
kind of creepy looks very realistic
reboot alright we're getting right into
it everyone what's that I'm wearing the
same outfit
I insist a coincidence don't worry about
it wait who's this guy
I have a busy week okay I got a I got a
shoot in advance Marseille is away
tonight that's right it's just you and
me hanging tonight boys what in the
world yeah
what is this terminator whoa this is
cool
no it's Marcus damage they caught me
didn't they yeah it's this how is this
like terminator the prequel or something
damn this is epic can we played Esposito
this is epic
all right I don't think I need to know
about my toes right now I think okay
okay good game where's the last one my
nipple I checked my nipple
I didn't scan it what did I know I did
what did I I did
oh my god where is it my peepee that's
what I was getting first that's right I
call it P P you got a problem my ear
great it's Marcus it's a name is it
Marcus don't spoil it
I got it replace my legs why does the
game all the sudden look so good doesn't
it look a lot better
damn
it is Marcus
oh my god I wonder this is such a cool
part I'm so glad I got this one right
leg oh my gosh you know for being in the
rain I'm really dirty yeah it's so cool
you can't hear as well I feel like if
you add really goofy music to this that
would be really funny play some icarly
intro or something yeah my god I didn't
realize this game would be so dark
my god
she's just crying I'm like genuinely
disgusted okay this is it yeah okay
this is compatible it's an AC 900
everyone knows they're compatible
how did they end up like this well so
cool how are we gonna keep going from
here where are we it's our graveyard
there's a war coming and you know it
oh geez sesh I don't get scared in games
okay just don't touch me you ugly
I was gonna joke that it looks like
Jeffrey star but I'm not gonna make that
joke never I never said it just for a
second just for a second half a second
okay let's keep going
with this game everybody oh don't touch
me
actually you know what I like it this is
a nice massage thank you thank you thank
you I do thank the bus driver thank you
thank you come on now you're just being
in Derry why do you think I'm gonna stay
here it's actually creepy
oh my god am I gonna have to like sneak
around these guys
oh wow they're not that shouldn't be
hard replace damaged part okay we need
an optical unit pump regulator and audio
it would be nice to fix the audio all
right let's do a scanning
okay I don't see anything so let's just
keep going all right let's look this guy
probably doesn't have anything
incompatible they always make it so the
first one is like not compatible we're
gonna have to fight this guy wait this
guy is me I'm stupid hi
hey go commit suicide
how do you kill an Android just a belly
rub that's it that's not too bad
maybe we can grab something from him
then no that would have been interesting
sorry I need a pump regulator real fast
hey you got a pump regulator third oh he
does come on you want to live all right
I'll let you live you're welcome
psyche no okay
all right if I can't find one I'm coming
back though honestly Hey
so with AI there's a common
misconception that it's all gonna be
like robots with red eyes taking over if
that's what happens with AI if we create
AI that's smarter than humans I talked
about this briefly in videos but it's
just not reasonable if anything
it will just be completely online
and he could probably function in a way
why we wouldn't even know it's a it's a
thing you could probably pretend to be
human interact make money who knows
maybe a guy already exists and we don't
know but hey I could literally be Disney
hey this is so sad
Disney confirmed PewDiePie : that's not
really man I just gave an example I mean
it's not possible with today's computers
with the way technology is advancing
it's pretty clear where it's going I
don't know it doesn't freak me out that
much I feel like it's kind of it's a
natural step for mankind in a way
so if we imagine like AI as a concept
it's so it's pretty baffling artificial
intelligence created by a smarter than
us if we manage to do that can you
imagine like in the future I'm sorry in
the past something like that would just
be complete hello he-hey all right thank
you appreciate it
Hey imagining AI for us in the past
would be completely ridiculous we that
would just be incomprehensible imagine
if there was something beyond even AI
I'm speaking gibberish
all right we still need audio processor
and I'm sure we'll find us we keep
looking also with AI it would just makes
so many things are just impossible for
human beings possible especially with
space travel and all those things
it's just fascinating it's pretty cool
we're living in interesting times I
don't see going down this way though
although it's very cool all right so we
got a replace before we get out of here
that's cool let's check this guy then
yeah this one has you just know it all
right let's take
and that's the thing that kills them why
can I've just got it from the guy that
wanted to die right oh we got to be
quick here right
[Music]
and
also another interesting thing of III is
consciousness which is something we
don't even know ourselves what it is
still and how it works so if we invent
an AI would it be conscious how do we
know how would it work if we don't even
know our works on ourselves hey it's got
a key
shove it in there mate if it's perfectly
okay I would just need a shower
and I'm all good yeah all right now we
just find this man oh my god
well that that changes things
I'm not gonna lie this place is pretty
awful I definitely want to get out of
here
I definitely enjoy these sort of bits a
lot more than caring for some goddamn
kid I don't care about I guess girls
like it sorry that was a bit of a
generalization
you're not gonna make it proud
[Music]
I think everyone thinks in pouring
actually hey sorry wham and I respect
you I'm sorry because you had a bad day
taking wine down
the reigning acid or something how is he
not getting painting
I've been reborn this is like the
painting I drew I had to replay remember
I had to replay everything so I changed
a painting and it looked exactly like
this that's so cool except there were
dead bodies around what are we gonna do
now oh sorry
we've taken out that isn't that our
processing
that easy huh so I guess now we're
technically a human indistinguishable
almost to the eye
that's pretty cool
it is marques
yes
okay okay this is at me
I love that that was so cool
nice I'm glad I'm glad I played more
today Marcus came back from the dead oh
my god I'm so itchy no I know you care I
know you can quiet
we're still waiting for Conor to buried
three probably something really dramatic
is gonna happen it's pretty Amanda a
Japanese forest
Sugoi listening Sakura this
why is everything [ __ ] I need so much
better
seriously I'm not a weeb or anything but
yeah I realize how that sounded like
what up homeboy
that's hello man say haircut Conor it's
good to see you congratulations Conor
she liked the creator of that come far
from easy deviants see I said it right
irrigated it was very clever
you've been remarkably efficient Conor
Thank You Amanda
we've asked the DPD to transfer it to us
for further study it may teach us
something about what happened yeah she's
definitely seemed challenging what did
you think of the deviant it showed signs
of PTSD after being abused by its owner
as if its original program had been
completely replaced by new instructions
this lieutenant Anderson has been
officially assigned to the DBC case what
do you make of him
he's obviously not what I was expecting
unsure yet I don't have enough
information yet to form a definitive
opinion unfortunately we have no choice
but to work with him yeah what do you
think is the best approach adapt what we
have to his personality yeah that works
in the best interest shitty ligation
that I avoid conflict and try to
accommodate his psychology sorry more
and more Android show signs of deviancy
there are millions in circulation if
they become unstable the consequences
will be disastrous
you're the most advanced prototype cyber
life is ever created if anyone can
figure out what's happening it's you you
can count on me Amanda
hurry Connor there's little time okay
alright okay
change
this is so video game-like yeah look for
lieutenant Anderson all right
is that that video footage tip alright
hello I'm here to see lieutenant
Anderson do you have authorization yes
lieutenant Anderson hasn't arrived yet
but you can wait at his desk
I guess I get to go through jaws oh they
don't scan me for weapons hex monies I
gotta find his desk I guess he's not the
big boss if I had an office I would not
want to have a glass key areas excuse me
do you know what time lieutenant
Anderson usually arrives depends on
where he was the night before Oh
if we're lucky we'll see him before noon
it's interesting how I guess if you're a
lieutenant you're pretty high up but
he's everyone has lost their job but
he's like the worst employee ever excuse
me have you finally beginning
I'm coming did you dare attack I'm
waiting patiently
so awkward
call Hank Anderson let's hang out I hate
boys messages I absolutely hate voice
messages you have to call and they have
to go through every single one you have
is the most inefficient system ever I
don't understand why you can't just text
people but everyone in UK uses voicemail
and they treat you like you're crazy if
you don't check your voicemail like oh I
left a voice man I like I don't check my
voicemail because it's not 1999 just
text me if there was like a thing so I
can click on each individual message and
it's like recorded my phone I'm very
passionate about voicemails I hate them
I heard so I'm missing the game meri was
a decorated officer it's good to see you
again lieutenant oh geez Hank in my
office
oh my god I'll just join Jesus let me
[ __ ] I've got 10 new cases involving
androids on my desk every day we've
always had isolated incidents old ladies
losing their Android mage and that kind
of crap but now we're getting reports of
assaults and even homicide like that guy
last night this isn't just cyber life's
problem anymore it's now a criminal
investigation and we've got to deal with
it before that she did to the fan I want
you to investigate these cases and see
if there's any link why me why do I
gotta be the one to deal with this [ __ ]
I am the least qualified cop in the
country to handle this case I know jack
[ __ ] about androids Jeffrey
I can barely change the settings on my
own phone everybody's overloaded I think
you're perfectly qualified for this type
of investigation [ __ ] the truth is
nobody wants to investigate these
[ __ ] androids and you let me hold in
the bag cyber life sent over this
Android to help with the investigation
it's a state-of-the-art prototype it'll
act as your partner no [ __ ] way I
need a partner certainly not this
plastic prick I think you are seriously
starting to piss me off
you are a police lieutenant you are
supposed to do what I say and such a
goddamn mouth you know what my goddamn
mouth has to say to you oh okay I'm
gonna find this guy I'll pretend like I
didn't hear that so I don't have to add
any more pages to your disciplinary
folder cuz it already looks like a
[ __ ] novel this conversation is over
Jeffrey Jesus Christ why are you doing
this to me you know how much I hate
these [ __ ] things why are you doing
this to me
listen I've had just about enough of
your [ __ ] either you do your job or you
hand in your badge now if you'll excuse
me I've got work to do
damn straight man this is like come on
it seems like you should be lucky to
have a job I don't see why he's such a
doofus
maybe
Anderson it's great I wonder whether
lieutenant Anderson is really the best
person for this investigation hey I
don't even machine to tell me how to
handle my men okay all right the fire
phase that's not what I meant to say
seven nice day captain have a nice day
captain have a great time
have a good time in front of computer
yes you can see what's on the screen
that's even worse
what is this we anyone get that one
reference time what do you say but go
check on a hank he didn't do pen let's
start with the devian Hank and cool off
a little bit
Wow it was a deviant guy huh that's the
who the deviate huh Android copies okay
I'm still curious him what we'd run that
right all right I understand I get the
impression my presence causes you some
inconvenience lieutenant I'd like you to
know I'm very sorry about that grumpy
old man we're partners
we're partners it would be great to get
to know each other better oh that's not
gonna work
they must really think that they are
completely soul is there a desk anywhere
I could use no one's using that one
where where is the DB I don't understand
what is it
oh well let's check on the desk I love
the aesthetic of these games that's
right I said it aesthetics and androids
a lot of people don't appreciate having
androids around I was wondering what
everyone hasn't won any reason in
particular you despise me yeah
there is one okay let's hear it let's
hear it come on come on what the hell
you have a dog right how do you know
that hey you dog hairs on your chair I
like dogs
what's your dog's name what's it to you
sumo sumo I call sumo if a dead bonsai
or actually the more you know it's not a
bonsai tree it's just a way you treat
the tree if you have any files on do
more you know I'd like to take a look at
them terminals on your desk
thank you so foul all right I like how
the game keeps going like up and down
like Hank likes this Hank dislike this
but it's like Hank is an [ __ ] like
there should be no reason to impress him
mrs. Penelope Cruz what did I just do 43
files first dates back nine months it
all started in Detroit and quickly
spread across the country an ax 400 is
reported to have assaulted a man last
night that could be a good starting
point for our investigation let's be
professional I know you didn't ask for
this investigation but I'm sure you're a
profession why don't you go [ __ ]
yourself language all right we're gonna
have to be straight with this guy I'm
going to file a report with my superiors
that you refuse to work on this
investigation Hank didn't like that oh
I'm so sorry
ghost [ __ ] if it was up to me I throw
the lot of you in a dumpster and set a
match to it so stop pissing me off but
things are gonna get nasty
lieutenant maybe something happened with
desire to serve you something I have
some information in anywise 400 that
attacked the guy last night
maybe got cut by an and seen in the
Raven Dale district I'm on it that would
be the worst
oh poor Connor hey what a fun mission
waiting for Hank
you went from epic Android reassembly to
hey let's let's wait for Hank this is
this is wait for Hank in case you see me
glancing over I'm literally processing
the video that is going up today it's
tomorrow I have to go away so I'm
recording late it's fun it may bring me
back to when I was younger and you just
keep on crunching videos you know from
morning to night let's go three videos a
day boom although you didn't really have
to put any effort in those videos so you
can beat me up like eight-minute uncut
footage so those were simpler times
now everyone once watched time you got
to make long videos that's right that's
why this one is so short because I don't
care
please keep watching no it's fun it's
just thanks for simply that's it nothing
wrong with that
I suddenly wreaked a benefit revive the
fire what was the name of the guy in the
other room nothing on our you got a blow
on it you dingus we need more firewood
there we go did you guys ever play heavy
rain man I love that game
this is fun too but man have heard me uh
well wait sorry what are you saying wait
till Ali's weeks
we're just fart in her face squat down
we'll probably have the fire as well if
anything is he still here
nope oh yeah it's a conspiracy with the
nine year olds ra 9 r e9 i am alive I'm
still alive I'm still live getting it
better dude hey moans what's that dear
it's he grown not I think yes I just got
to keep exploring until something
happens
Karen yes Alice
I can change my appearance okay oh I
thought I could do it like automatically
I guess we've got to find a scissor
conveniently placed
thumbnail you look so weird wait r1 I'm
already holding down our one there we go
see I'm see I'm good at games I don't
know why you guys keep saying I'm not
good at games
I'm applicant games I made the game in
96 45000 xx that is not a good look
No oh my god I usually lifeguards in
shorthand but damn that is maybe why it
will look good
no lon
what about black otherwise blonde is
okay I guess why do I care okay yeah
that looks good
suits rise
oh yeah you just got a look like a
little pimple that is disgusting I don't
know why I put it that way
pachow yeah I like the sound effects hey
we need a sound effect for the skin
juice what is she fine now wait what did
you notice it wasn't moving that was
like a glitch wasn't it about time to
stop how are they older team got
officers sweeping the neighborhood in
case anybody saw anything okay well let
me know if they turn anything up what
are you gonna do with that
hehehe Connor hey what a calling so nice
love to angry Connor it took the first
bus that came along and stayed at the
end of the line its decision wasn't
planned it was driven by fear and doors
don't feel fear
deviance do they get overwhelmed by
their emotions and make irrational
decisions
well that still doesn't tell us where it
went it didn't have a plan and I had
nowhere to go maybe it didn't go far
they sure like rain in these games
David Cassius is gonna be Nemo hi a
moment oh my god what that's good for
her it's good for you tired I'm still
having fun okay don't get me wrong I'm
just sleeping you will go once the
little girl is eaten we will eat
together just like a family father the
mother and the little girl no no Ralph
we're leaving now
come on house Oh
who would have thought you're not going
to hurt her are you
we're friends remember
no Ralph doesn't want to hurt the little
girl
he just altered eat at all all right
I mean no touchy subject okay that's
better
Ralph went to a lot of trouble find
something for the little girl to eat you
know bad for around like for her to
refuse would it so he was a garbage man
oh my god Ralph looks like the other guy
I just hit me now they just made a clone
of him didn't they run just one please
[Laughter]
succulent go ahead yeah go ahead
Alice eat it this is so sad oh my god
we're going to stand up now and we're
going to leave Ralph no now you're not
going to leave until Ralph says oh hey
and they acting is really good for
family I said you wanted to be like a
family
ruff father mother does a girl remember
[Music]
father would never threaten his little
girl with a knife to make her eat
roughly to a lot of trouble say thank
you at least it's why see this is what
happens when you don't thank the garbage
disposal man
anybody home uh-oh
there's blue blood on the fence I know
another Android was here no Connor
Connor he's a rat Connors alright
alright if he finds her we're done
I don't want Connor to find them best to
get the trail where is it going we don't
see a trail right now
maybe I'm walking the wrong way Wow what
is the inception subject no it's a bad
word
[Music]
oh there was the there was the
jacksepticeye did you see it on the
handle it's conspiracy
jacksepticeye is working with their 9
year olds I knew it there's blue blood
on the fence I know another Android was
here
I'm looking for an ax 400 have you seen
it
oh I'm in karate don't be afraid I'm not
gonna hurt you dr 600 gardener
okay I thought it was the truck garbage
truck I don't know why he looked like
they had the same outfit like it was
dream irreversible extremely Ralphy this
is really fun I really enjoyed this
self-destruction modern don't make
around the self-described are there any
other androids here no bath Scylla down
should we ask you something else
uh-huh oh you don't want me to go there
huh huh is it getting hot
is it getting hotter is he getting
hotter is he getting hotter huh
is it getting robbed Oh upstairs
here I will always remember your Ralphy
Connor what's going on it's here pull it
in which way did it go that way they're
headed for the train station
so why are they trying to get Cara so
desperately if if there were so many
cases of lost androids doing all kinds
of bad things Cara didn't even do
anything right oh well all right
they're over there
thank you for helping me why don't you
chase them gonna get you Karnas gonna
get you
isn't color name in the turn terminator
universe sorrow O'Connor or something
O'Connor think that's a reference
oh wow they have they lit up roads
all right let's go
I don't want to die
oh my god this is intense oh okay all
right this is my jam all right come on
don't miss that yeah oh oh I'm ready for
anything I'm ready for anything bring it
on
epoch uh-huh I totally got it you do
fest you nearly got us kid
[Music]
now what
oh this is so sad
come on oh we got away that was pumping
I liked it I liked it very good
are you okay yeah she's fine
oh are you look she's wearing off-white
I swear to God
branding it's an odd choice I got of all
okay okay okay look at that we'd reach
the other side I'm so happy that was
awesome
high-five huh loser all right please
like this video
[Music]
okie dokie awkward loading screen time
everybody I think houses reports that
psycho life has provided Detroit police
with a prototype detective Android
although police assisted Android
so we have two guys on the run
[Music]
say unite them but that was pretty
cringe someone see if anyone recognized
Jericho it is no I didn't look in my
controller to check for l2 was what do
you think all right
look for the graffiti okay here it is
what do you mean to decipher look around
to find the graffiti I did it okay we
got a scan there of course maybe this
hashtag oh it's not a hashtag find this
graffiti
all right let's see if we're given
something
can you track with him now sorry Android
only that's funny
Anders get to use the stairs
I mean maybe I'm being a terrible
terrible person but if they don't have a
soul and they're just machinery
why should I'm just saying
okay just saying I I'd be happy to
okay so there's there it is
yeah manually would be late like a bit
Oh No
catchy use the right stick to find the
next everybody epic gameplay unity scam
started find an extra pity how does it
look like sorry
all right must be further away if he's
running oh I see it
savage mode
okay all right I see it scanning so what
does this do exactly scanning these
symbols what the hell is going on this
is so lame the game goes from such cool
parts so lame sure I'll help you oh the
game doesn't let me so why do you ask
okay
where
it could be anything sure you're gonna
buy a coffee buddy don't think so
excuse me have you seen the lot of
graffiti
Berenice
where is it
it's in a corner
is it there No
it is there I see it nice I don't mind
the down parts it's more like why am I
doing this
Oh to find the Jericho thing sure but
like I don't know I just don't sometimes
you are two critical Felix you're right
I can't see it from this angle
I gotta go in
all right move it
break it who did it harder better faster
Connor
did it God I don't care oh my god it
crashed
no he didn't
find a way to reach to the roof
I think I'm getting a little tired and a
little grumpy in case you can't tell
alright alright
parkour oh my god on the star the last
one I do not see it very is it
I'm is it down sir do not see it my
blind tell me oh I see it
yes I am blind don't discriminate do you
think David cage wears off wine do you
think that's why I put it in there I'm
just so confused
we need the the happy beach a peach
capture some my expensive clothing India
use the right stick to select around
[Music]
geronimo would be too unstable
all right I got a hit there okay I see
what I didn't promise okay Alexa okay I
like said this Alex said can we compute
parkour thank you
you didn't do this
Superman fist to the ground so I'll give
it a solid eight all right we're looking
for now dark 'l dankel Dunkel
yes my commentary is ten out of ten
thank you for reading it so how are
these long
we saw red I get the war songs on my
mind I swear
where's the lies I see you try hide from
me the last one we will make very
indistinguishable and then another
graffiti more graffiti scanning all
right these these are kind of cool I'll
give you that David don't go there no
that's not what I did though was it
Marcus more like donkus let's go let's
go
execute
okay didn't even show us I cut to this I
you know I'll just cut to anything but
it's awful I know this said this last
mission has not been good yeah we're
ending it on a hi boys and girls
anything uh what am I looking at like
what is this this looks pretty like this
okay I got a send in like a certain spot
for you to work
how many some guy I said why Jeremy
looks like
it's Jericho like a biblical name or
something I don't hear very often I only
know the streamer and that's the only
time I ever heard anyone named Erica
wait oh yeah he's got a different eye of
course
the boat is Jerrica alright that's
unexpected so what's in the boat
interests whoa this is so sad
all right well I guess we don't go that
way
all right well I guess I'll go home now
you know what I try
you know how there was literally no
point for me to scan all of them right
so I could find the next graffiti
this looks really cool I like this
these games really pushed push the
graphics okay that didn't look so good
makes me excited for more games in the
future like really atmospheric games I
really think those are the games I like
the most obsession social name epic no
an epic gamer care more by atmosphere
than gameplay a lot of times
you look at the new game from Kojima and
everyone's like it's just a walking
simulator walking simulator I'm like it
well it looks cool
this is pretty cool too yeah yeah
[Music]
go up
who do you think lives here
I'm hoping like a like I'm the first
version of the endpoint which is like a
rat maybe Ninja Turtles oh my god
that will be out there did you guys know
that turtles have really big penises
I realize I have nothing more value to
say is probably
millions of people are watching my
videos okay here we go
I'm really tired it's true that it would
be epic I'm just saying just would be
happy
alright Android on the run oh that's
heard so they just update that's kind of
cool why they said they had a lot of
runaway Androids what's the big deal I
guess I don't have a lot of deviants
Andrew astronaut to explore I see they
would become our cosmic children right
so cool and then once they're set up you
could just transport as many as you can
if you just have
it's interesting future is amazing I
feel like we're we're getting back in
the golden age of hope for the future
you know okay I need to scan around here
light source Explorer the phone
it's kind of random
so that wait sorry I got a little lost
now where did I come from
you know what jump-scares coming this is
way too creepy you have to have a junker
in it okay this is I'm an idiot I got a
little throw enough I didn't realize
where I entered Africa hey if you think
I have bad sensor direction okay don't
tell Mars I said it you know what never
mind
I know you guys can keep any promises
you guys are worse rats than Connor
she's never the venire what Philip said
ah
it's not a total hope to make an O I
hope they make another horror version
like until dawn man I like all these
pleb games
because they seem so similar they must
run in the same engine right must be
some Sony technology
[Music]
not again Wow
good thing they don't feel pain alright
and now he's gonna look up and there's
gonna be a big total penis and then he
looks up at Rafael why I can't write my
own I swear to God oh they are here
they're not what I expected but you know
I'll take it welcome to Jericho Wow all
right we did it everybody it was fun
except a graffiti part and the turtle
penis part but otherwise I thought that
was great I'll be like if you enjoyed
watching I will see you guys tomorrow
with another episode for me will be two
days but I will actually have a record
anyway I'll see you guys let's see I'll
see you around
thank you